when companies come out with new
features and different tech it's always
really exciting to get hands-on and play
with it but when companies like Apple
come out with new tech it always cost a
small fortune to upgrade to the next big
thing what's going on guys my name is
Debbie Tom H and welcome back to the
channel today we're talking about the
2019 MacBook Pros touch bar across the
top and yes we are only talking about
the little piece of OLED glass that
replaces the function keys for those of
you who've been following my channel for
a while now you may have noticed that
the audio quality wasn't that great
before well I listened to the comments
that you guys put down in the videos and
I went out and bought a little lapel mic
so I'm hoping that the audio quality in
this video here is a little bit better
and that we can keep growing this
channel every single day if you haven't
already subscribed make sure you smash
that subscribe button and let's get on
today's video if you're watching this
video here it's more likely that you're
comparing the MacBook Pro with the touch
bar and without the touch bar well if
you live in Australia right now there's
end of financial year sales on and you
can get the MacBook Pro without the
touch bar for about 1900 others if you
want the version with the touch bar it's
$2,400 so it's $500 difference for just
a little tiny touch bar across the top
of the keyboard today I want to find out
with you guys is it really worth it and
in my opinion should you go out and
spend that extra money for a tiny little
piece of glass so if you don't know
where what the touch bar is already
basically the touch bar is the little
piece of glass at the top of the
keyboard that replaces the original
function keys that were there before it
continuously updates and changes with
different little icons and symbols
depending on what kind of program you're
using or what software you're in now one
of the best features about the MacBooks
touch bar is a touch ID in the top right
hand corner if you've ever used the
phone with a touch ID fingerprint
scanner you know exactly what it does
but basically it allows you to sign in
to your computer
signage different apps and also make
transactions really quickly and really
easily when you finally signed in to
your macbook with the touch ID you're
gonna notice three main icons along with
series one of the icons is brightness
and the other two are volume you're also
going to notice a little triangle to the
left of that which allows you to expand
that whole touch bar across and give you
more features if you want to increase
the volume for example you just tap the
volume and drag it up and down which is
kind of a little cool and unique feature
that's different everybody else's laptop
now one thing I would recommend to you
guys is changing the little Siri I con
to potentially like something like the
spotlight search the spotlight search is
going to get used a hell of a lot more
than the Siri feature so you can go into
settings and change it out to almost
anything that you like in my honest
opinion straight off the bat only using
it for a couple minutes I thought you
know what this is kind of fun but at the
same time it's kind of gimmicky so I
wanted to explore it a bit more and take
it through a couple apps that were
standard installs in the MacBook Pro
obviously I ran it through a chrome and
a couple other programs and again it was
quite fun it allowed you to do shortcuts
really quickly which I guess is the
whole point of the touch bar it really
lets you speed up the process one of the
best things is that the fact that touch
bar has actually been out for about
three years now so all the software
developers have had time to play
catch-up and introduce their own
software updates to incorporate these
little icons into the touch bar so if
you're doing movie editing photo
anything or anything like that chances
are there's a little scrub bar at the
bottom that's gonna let you really move
through the movies a lot quicker
I'll move through photos of these slides
and things like that even though that
touch bar looks really nice with its
OLED display and its matte glass finish
it does like I mentioned before replace
the function keys that were there
previously so if you're like me who does
use those function keys quite a bit to
switch between apps and programs it's
kind of a bummer because it's not as
easy to switch through programs as it
was before that's basically all the
touch bar really does it's just there to
give you different graphics and
different logos to kind of get you more
invited into the program I guess and to
speed up the process sometimes if you
get used to it it probably does help you
speed up the process a lot more but
personally I haven't used it that much
to be able to really tell you guys if
it's worth it if it's going to speed up
your workflow enough to justify the
difference but in my personal opinion I
don't think that an extra five hundred
dollars for a touch bar that just gives
you different graphics instead of
learning keyboard shortcuts is worth the
money and that's my review of the math
book touch bar if you enjoyed the video
make sure you smash that subscribe
button maybe drop a comment let me know
what you'd like to see next and
hopefully I'll see you next Monday
you